radhika you may know has made a daunting
list of many wonderful and always
innovative movies only going to name a
handful of them making sure that you
have seen them because they are
wonderful mother and child 9 lives which
he shot new every every one of the short
stories and nine lives
he shot with one single take one long
single 15 minute or so 10 min or so take
astonishing work oscar-nominated Albert
Nobbs things you can tell just by
looking at her and the long-running HBO
series in treatment he also does tons of
pilots which are always so good if you
can get him to do your pilot you are
you're in clover he also write I wrote a
movie that I want you to see that it's
called last days in the desert and in
fact just yesterday in a writers room
that I'm working in right now someone
brought up his film and that room
launched into a half-hour discussion of
last days in the desert it's a haunting
movie it's quite original stars Ewan
McGregor in its streaming on a number of
sites you can buy it on Amazon your
homework of the night is to go home and
see this extraordinary movie so after
that embarrassing build up I'm going to
give you a Rodrigo Garcia
thank you very much I am humbled by that
introduction but humility is my favorite
form of vanity so I'm okay Thank You Don
and Robin good evening everyone and
welcome everyone even those of you who
would rather watch a movie than write a
movie count me among you where our
writers sitting today huh very good so
here's the story I heard from the genre
of anecdote a very well-to-do elderly
lady from Columbia was travelling with
her dog from New York to Bogota upon
arrival the container and dog were
nowhere to be found
the lady was well known in a close
friend of the owner of the airline so
the news reaches the president of the
airline and heaven and earth are moved
in the search for the dog after 36 hours
the container is finally found in a
remote airport but inside the little dog
is found dead already starting to
decompose a desperate middle-level
airline executives suggest that perhaps
another dog can be found that resembles
the deceased dog and they given her age
and failing senses the owner might not
notice the difference in a panic the
plan is put into motion and executives
show up at the lady's apartment with the
new dog she takes one look at it and
says that's not my dog my dog was dead I
was bringing it home to bury it
so this story contains some good themes
emotional attachment loss class and
privilege death respect and disrespect
for the elderly and perhaps greatest of
all human folly but it's best told
quickly because it has holes and I won't
point them out they'll come to you on
the way home here's another story from
the genre of personal history my father
who was the author of the novel 100
Years of Solitude died aged 87 at noon
on a good Thursday he had been back from
the hospital for a few days and doctors
had already prepared us for the worst
outcome a few hours before noon earlier
that same morning a bird was found dead
inside the house what was once a Terrace
had been enclosed a few years earlier to
make for a sitting area overlooking the
garden the walls are glass so it was
surmised that the bird flew in became
disoriented crashed against the glass
and fell dead on the sofa more precisely
on the spot where my dad regularly sits
my father's secretary informed me that
the employees in the house and office
were divided into two groups those who
think it's a bad omen and want the bird
thrown into a trash can and those who
think it's a good omen and want the bird
buried among the flowers in the garden
the trash ist's have taken the upper
hand and the bird is already in a
garbage can outside the kitchen after
further debate the bird is placed in a
corner of the garden above-ground for
now while its final destination is
decided nobody outside the house knows
anything about the dead bird a few hours
later that same afternoon shortly after
the news of my father's death is made
public his secretary receives an email
from a friend she hasn't talked to in a
long time the friend wanted to know if
we were aware that or sulig were on one
of my father's most famous characters
had also died on a good Thursday the
friend has included in her email a
passage from one hundred years of
solitude and in rereading it my dad's
secretary discovers that after all so
his death disoriented birds flew into
walls and fell dead on the ground she
reads me her friend's email and looks at
me puzzled perhaps hoping I am foolish
enough to venture an opinion on the
coincidence I don't all I know is I
can't wait to retell it this second
story has some good themes - premonition
coincidence destiny death and the
invisible strings that perhaps bind
everything together in the universe and
of course the marriage of life and
storytelling now here's a brief one
something from the genre of scientific
writing from the book Homo sapiens by
Yuval Noah Harare I quote six million
years ago a single female ape had two
daughters one became the ancestor of all
chimpanzees the other is our grandmother
wow what a story from one of these
little creatures who shall remain
forever unknown and unknowing and from
her mate who perhaps would have been
less willing had he foreseen the
consequences from them flowed the vast
torrent of people that brought his love
cathedrals rice noodles war music and
justice paintings of water lilies babies
laughing suicide the World Cup sexting
banking high heels and an incalculable
number of individuals all the way to
here - Malala and Donald Trump the dog
story has two terrific elements surprise
and humor it's a fine it's a fine enough
one-night stand
one-night stand but it's no love affair
the second and third stories offer the
most rare and powerful of elements
mystery why that bird on that day why
that baby ape why her the more your
story works the more it makes sense the
more grounded it is I think the more
mystery it needs so that is my
recommendation to our winners today
beyond my congrat
relations keep mystery and your stories
something something always always
something unknown and unknowable beyond
the extensible motivations of your
characters beyond cause and effect
beyond the tears shed trying to solve
the second part of the second act beyond
the ruthless notes of executives that
demand that everything be explained and
early and quickly and twice a good story
should always include something about
the depths of the human soul and of its
most closely held secrets and about the
infinite universe and of our short and
puzzling time on this planet so that's
the challenge people stories both
grounded and mysterious good luck with
that
thank you
sadly the part of the ceremony that is
about me is over so let us greet our
players this evening she recently
starred in the feature film before I
fall her credits include why him
everybody wants some dirty grandpa
beautiful creatures and the upcoming the
year of spectacular men and set it up
Zoe Deutsch
[Applause]
she most recently starred in Beauty and
the Beast and the television series
black mirror next she'll be appearing in
God particle and a wrinkle in time other
credits include miss Sloan beyond the
lights Gugu and bata raw
he currently stars in the HBO series
West world and recently completed work
on the Cuban feature 1989 his other
feature credits include for Focus 300
rise of an empire and love actually
control that ego Santoro
in Love Actually Rodrigo played a
handsome man with the help of
prosthetics an actor producer and
screenwriter widely known for his
leading roles in hacksaw bridge wedding
crashers among many other movies his
other credits include the internship
into the wild mr. and mrs. Smith
most recently he starred in brawl in
cell block 99 Vince Vaughn
[Applause]
okay